Tim hunt welcome to this interview with
nobelprize.org you won the 2001 nobel
prize for physiology or medicine
together with Lee Hartwell and paul
nurse correct and you seem to have been
blessed with the lucky chance of knowing
that you wanted to be a biologist or a
chemist from quite early very yeah very
very early on it was entirely because i
think i was sort of scientifically
minded but I you know and I can't really
remember it's a construct now but I did
very well in a biology exam when I was I
think 11 years old or something like
that and I came out somehow 13th in the
whole school in those days you know you
everybody took the same science exam
whether you were seven or what was a
1230 99 and so you knew exactly when I
was kind of in the middle of that point
you know no and I did I did very well
and I realized that it just we know it
came very naturally to me and I also
knew I mean another thing I had a great
friend who was a really good physicist
I'm United an FRS and all that stuff
Peter pewsey and he was so much better
at physics than I was you know I liked
physics I would have loved to been good
at physics but the fact of the matter
was I just wasn't you know Peter was
zoomed ahead you know a man's gotta know
his limitations dumb so I think he's
terribly important to know what you're
good at and what you're not
you